bonjour à tous le mwc touche à sa fin
j'en ai profité j'ai vu plein plein de
trucs là en tant que super cool je les
fais plein de vidéos
j'ai vu aussi des trucs assez what the
fuck donc du coup je vous ai fait une
petite vidéo what the fuck pour vous
montrer alors vous allez voir il
regrette le truc marrant c'est pas non
plus la grande folie mais ya franchement
de quoi se marrer
là c'est la fin tout le monde démontre
ce soir wouah ici que ce soit ibm ici ou
alors carrément les normes stand de
samsung dc où tout le monde fait la fête
c'est la fin tout le monde se casse
donc voilà alors dans cette vidéo ce
toshiba je vous présente tous un petit
moment c'est what the fuck tous ces
trucs que j'ai rencontré et en plus de
ça à la fin vous allez bras j'ai passé
un bon coup de gueule contre airbnb
pense qu'ils vont bien foutu dans la
merde parce qu'avoir un logement à se
retrouver à la rue à 21h c'est pas cool
mais ça je vous le dis dans la partie
[Musique]
vous avez une version revue et corrigée
de fort boyard mais récolte des boyards
jeu
c'est complètement dingue ce truc une
espèce de kébé d'une ventilation par le
bas des billets projeté à quoi je ne
sais pas ce que le mec en fait ils les
gardent il n'ya pas il se fait une
petite cagnotte qui les donne à des
associations comme dans fort boyard
viens viens bien aux boîtes the fuck
on a le drone taxi pour vous embarquez
vous et votre famille directement dans
les airs mais dont on aura plus taxi on
va puis s'emmerder on va directement
prendre de la hauteur
ce drone taxi tel c'est dingue parce que
c'est un
place monoplace nous place avec une
commande au milieu qu'on peut
effectivement piloter vous avez des
hélices énorme des portes qui se lève
sur le côté c'est vraiment un truc hyper
impressionnant vous assez raide ans et
vous emmènera où vous voulez il sera
piloté automatiquement probablement dans
point a à un point b et vous
tranquillement couvrent leurs et dans
les airs
[Musique]
il
je suis pas si on se rend bien compte
l'homme il est en train de neiger voilà
donc on est le disent pas de bêtises le
27 février on est bientôt en mars à
barcelone
normalement ici il fait beau il fait
chaud banon la neige cool voilà donc ça
c'est un petit peu what the fuck aussi
c'est à dire mwc où tu pars de france tu
dis fait très froid ici va faire chaud
banon ici li neige si vous vous demandez
qu'est ce que le club et où est le club
ché la réponse l'est juste ici derrière
moi c'est une espèce d'énorme nuage
contre une sur le stand de messages bird
voice sms chat et voilà enfin j'ai
trouvé au clair il est là bien
évidemment qui dit salon international
sur le mobile 10 chaînes internationales
est derrière moi vous avez si elle est
juste là c'est gros gros boulot chez eux
on est fatigué
journée pour y était le patron derrière
à ses partenaires c'est un salon
fatiguant dacquois toute la journée
voilà cnn il ya si nbc de l'autre côté
il ya toutes les chaînes espagnoles bien
évidemment j'ai pas encore croisé le
média français mais mon avis ça ne
saurait tarder quand on smartphone prend
l'eau priori ces résistants sont sans
eau depuis un petit moment et pas mal
mais ça qu'avec certification ip68 on a
plutôt tendance à se dire que ça protège
des éclaboussures de la poussière mais
dès lors pour lumière pendant des heures
comme ça j'aimerais bien voir la tronche
du produit au bout de quelques jours
complètement immergé alors là j'imagine
effectivement c'est une vie nos clochers
in une hausse à l'école donc forcément
ça craint beaucoup moins mais malgré
tout je me demande la durée de vie de la
série oz the fuck vous avez de la
réalité virtuelle avec htc plusieurs
personnes en train de jouer avec un
téléphone hier plusieurs personnes en
train de jouer à travers un jeu de
shooting
ils se voient tous ensemble ils shootent
c'est super phone
[Musique]
non
il
la montgolfière avec le casque de
réalité virtuelle du htc de la
montgolfière virtuel ça c'est aussi
plutôt pas mal pour les robots tic a pas
longtemps si vous avez suivi sur la kobo
tic
on parlait de robots industriels lors
d'un énorme machine un peu rock the fuck
qui est l'implantation sur le site de
china mobile qui est un site qui est
juste dingue en immersion complète avec
un écran énorme du haut jusqu'en moi
c'est pas si on voit bien c'est vraiment
un truc
so what the fuck et cette machine est
fait peur regardez-le tritz avait dû
perdre
voilà pour cette vidéo de what the fuck
merci d'avoir regardé merci en tout cas
nous avoir suivi sur le mwc alors il va
y avoir encore plein de vidéos je pense
que à l'heure où je publierai cette
vidéo je n'aurais pas encore publié j'ai
vu tellement de choses il est tellement
contenu que bon voilà donc merci à vous
et je vous faire maintenant un petit
coup de gueule pour vous expliquer ce
qui m'est arrivé quand je suis arrivé je
suis arrivé la veille la veille au soir
- bienne be j'avais contacté le mec
plusieurs fois par l'internet qui
m'avait pas répondu par un sms de lui au
téléphone il donne son adresse et me dit
ok c'est bon j'ai l'appel à 19h le mec
qui me dit bon ben ok ok mais je
j'arrive même jour pas de réservation en
votre nom mais j'arrive le mec n'est
jamais arrivé je me suis retrouvé dans
la rue si votre acte airbnb qui m'a dit
et d'écouté ont réussi et de contacts et
lui ont valu envoyer un message
ils l'ont contacté toujours pas donné de
réponse ni eux ni à moi le problème dans
tout ça si vous voulez c'est qu'à la fin
je me retrouve vient d'indiquer à la rue
et la solution derby hennebicq on vous
êtes à la rue à 21h le soir dans une
ville étrangère ou de toute façon tous
les hôtels sont complets et dans les
hôtels qui rêve qui sont à cinq cent
mille euros la nuit et vous envoie une
liste avec 10-15 adresse différente
ils vous disent contacter les tous et
vos questionnaires qui peut vous
hébergez vous répondre donc ça veut dire
que lorsque par airbnb quelqu'un vous
plante juillet mme vieira effectivement
pour prendre le relais et vous proposer
les adresses dans un budget qui a déjà
beaucoup plus élevé que celui que vous
avez caillou début mai six personnes
vous réponds vous êtes à la rue c'est
parce qu'ils ont beau bouquin hôtel
ces peuples ont trouvé une solution pour
ça c'est vraiment le plus dur parce que
je pense que ça c'est à s'emmerder
on peut retrouver vraiment à la rue
alors là j'ai eu la chance je viens qui
m'a répondu assez vite donc j'ai pu être
relogés ça m'a quand même coûté beaucoup
plus cher l'histoire un plus de foi de
prix mais bon moi j'étais pas leurs yeux
donc voilà ça c'est pas bien
vous félicite perdition en tout cas
quant à vous je vous remercie beaucoup
de m'avoir suivi merci est toujours plus
présent sur la chaîne on est extrêmement
nombreux et ça c'est vraiment génial et
continuer parce que vous allez voir il
va encore plus de surprises plein de
choses des smartphones de la téléphonie
mobile
il va y avoir de l'intelligence
artificielle de la saint jean la
robotique truc de dingue
voilà je vous laisse un gros bisou je
vais partir du mwc je veux aller bouffer
des cas parce j'ai beaucoup de travail
en portant à une nouvelle fois derrière
moi là là bonjour la voiture donc voilà
je vous laisse à très bientôt
merci beaucoup n'oubliez pas vos sacs
les meilleurs et à bientôt